change why she had to be done July's
change organizations guy [ __ ] he
organized
I might change the world
truly a pleasure to be here of course
being a good businessman I tried to size
up the competition and checked on who's
been here
thank you three meetings ago you had the
CEO Citigroup one of those institutions
that are too big to fail but keep
failing
and you had partner from McKinsey and
last week as you mentioned Dean you had
the president of Turkey so a banker a
consultant and a politician and you're
rounding up that list of most popular
institution with Big Oil's but seriously
it's indeed nice to be here I I of
course love the Bay Area I had the
fortune that Aramco sent me here on a
developed on a working assignment in San
Francisco back early in my career in the
very early 80s and like all of you
you're I'm sure this is an area that one
can't resist and then of course our
company extends back in history our
roots are actually in the Bay Area
Aramco Saudi Aramco is the Saudi Arabian
oil company today but we started with a
concession to Standard Oil of California
and the first name of the company that
ran that concession was called
California Arabian Standard Oil Company
so California was a head of Arabian and
in the roots of Saudi Aramco and of
course to top it off just a couple of
weeks ago my youngest son has announced
that he's joining Stanford in September
so this is just around
so you may be seeing more of me in the
future but it's it's truly a pleasure to
be here this is the finest school in my
opinion on many fronts and certainly the
business school ranks as one of the best
and in fact I have some of my colleagues
for products of your executive education
program and also the school of Earth
Sciences those historic links with with
the institution are reflected in many
ways today I mentioned colleagues we
have 40 Stanford graduates the highest
of which is actually the chairman of
Saudi Aramco and our minister of
petroleum who is also a graduate of the
school of Earth Sciences and geology and
we have 13 students who are enrolled
here I hope some of them are here ok
good
I saw a 13 hands if not you are gonna
hear from me
but we also had 30 MBAs I understand
earlier this year I tried to meet them
when they were here any of them bees who
came to Saudi Arabia and in the crowd
today and visited the company I see a
few hands I hope you enjoyed your trip
and it was instructive and useful for
you and certainly we hope that more of
these exchanges between our employees
and the students of Stanford will be
continuing in the future later on
tonight I will be having the pleasure of
joining with your Provost at chemin D
dr. Rachael Andy and some of the
leadership of the school of Earth
Sciences to celebrate an endowment that
Saudi Aramco is putting in place to
endow a chair and the name of Max
Steiner Keith at the Dean has talked
about our first chief geologist and a
pioneer and every meaning of the world
if I can elaborate in what he said this
man who came from very humble beginnings
had his education here at Stanford who
went and tried finding oil and Indonesia
and Alaska and elsewhere and just
thought that the frontier place to go to
was the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia so he
called Chevron said you just signed a
concession with the kingdom and I want
to be part of it and he was sent to a
country with no roads no airports no air
conditioning no electricity for that
matter literally a country that was
hundreds of years behind at that time in
terms of infrastructure and amenities to
support life and he mapped the whole
kingdom there were no Maps and started
drilling after five years of frustration
the headquarters office and San
Francisco Opera Road sent a cable to
to the people in the field and order
them to stop working
well max didn't want to hear of this so
he hid the instruction from his team and
they were drilling at that time the 7th
world and ordered them to drill a little
deeper after receiving a distraction
well the rest is history because
drilling a little deeper they discovered
our first gusher our first commercial
oil discovery and the mom number seven
which became lucky number seven and
later on was named by the king of the
kingdom as the prosperity world well
since then more oil has been produced by
our companies than any other company in
the world so it's in there inspired by
this instruction and the spirit of
Steiner cave drilling a little deeper
that I would like to talk to you today
I'd like to drill a little deeper about
Saudi Aramco and I think the Dean did a
good job of giving you some of the
top-line numbers and our position of the
market but for you to really make sense
of my views from the top as lecture
series is called you really need to
understand what is happening at the
bottom so to speak and a cross-section
of functions and levels of the company
so I will try to drill a little bit
deeper about what around Co is what it
is context and how it runs its business
nationally globally and the very
important energy markets now one thing I
want to be careful because I know this
lecture is taped and I want later on to
be used as evidence I am NOT encouraging
any of you to refuse the instructions of
your bosses when they ask you to do
something so although we're we're very
happy with the fact that Stein Ackley
continued drilling and discovered oil
the and 10
always we encourage our people to do
listen to instructions from their
management let me start by giving you
that in depth
presentation about what the company does
and where we are as I mentioned we
produce more oil than any other company
the D mentioned that we're producing 10%
actually the numbers has gone up you can
count today that we produce one out of
every seven barrels of oil produced
around the world that is 10 million out
of about 72 barrels
72 million barrels of oil that are
produced globally Saudi Aramco is also a
significant Gaza gas producer we are one
of the top gas producers in the world we
have we're the only one that has any
spare production capacity to speak of as
a company we have more than half of the
global spare oil production capacity so
our decisions on production our ability
to respond or god forbid not not being
able to respond could have consequences
not only to the oil market but to the
global economy that are not equalled or
not matched by any other company in the
world this of course requires not just
reserves and resources which we have
plenty of but it requires unique
capabilities operational capabilities
technical capabilities financial
capabilities management and leadership
capabilities and the ability to lead in
a business that is the most politicized
of any business the oil market is highly
politicized as you all know and
downstream in addition to that dominant
position in the upstream we are also
quite sizable we have joint ventures
around the world and we
sizeable refining capacity in the
kingdom and our operations range from
here in the US all the way extending in
China and in Japan and Korea in Asia in
terms of our financial position we're
probably one of the very few probably
the only company I know of of our size
and scale that have no debt on our
balance sheet we are so strong
financially that we have been you know
financially long and our cash flow for
as long as I can remember we pay taxes
and royalty and we have an arm's length
relationship with with the shareholder
which is the tax collector at the same
time we fund our own capital and
operating expenditures and then we pay
dividends afterwards but we've never
been in a situation where we as Saudi
Aramco have to borrow money to fund our
operations so we're fiscally responsible
and capable as a company of course with
this competence financial position and
influence on global markets energy and
otherwise there comes a lot of
responsibility that comes a lot of
global responsibility because we always
look at the influence that oil has on
global economy and we have to manage
that relationship very carefully but
also being the national oil company of a
developing country like Saudi Arabia
that is still relatively early in its
development cycle we have a unique
responsibility within the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia to leverage everything we
have and enable the acceleration of the
development of the kingdom we are of
course the predominant source of revenue
for the kingdom we are the only supplier
of energy to businesses utilities and
individuals within the kingdom but
beyond that we are expected to do a lot
more
in addition to what you would expect an
oil and gas company to have that
drilling the subsurface reservoir
management the vast operating plant for
upstream midstream and downstream given
the concentration and complexity of our
oil and gas core business and the scale
of what we do we also run a lot of
support businesses that are unique for
any company of any kind we have a
significant fleet of aircraft both
fixed-wing and helicopter to manage our
operations we have hundreds of marine
vessels that manage both our offshore
production as well as our transportation
of crude around the world we have
housing compounds that houses tens of
thousands of our employees and their
families we have remote area camps that
support our plants in the desert we have
a health care system that has hundreds
of thousands of patients that will fully
support on all of their medical care so
the company an addition of being at
scale to say the least in oil and gas we
have all of these unique and diverse
support services that make Saudi Aramco
indeed one of acount
one of a kind now because of the breadth
and complexity of these various mandates
that I talked about the international
the national the business it is always a
challenge to remind ourself to stay
close to our mission and let me just say
for for your sake what the mission is
Saudi Aramco's mission as an integrated
international company is to engage in
all activities related to the
hydrocarbon industry on a commercial
basis and for the purpose of profit this
is a very focused and a very smartly
written mission statement to remind us
that despite everything I said about the
international the geopolitical the
macroeconomic
impact of the company that ultimately at
our core just like any other
multinational company and the other
private company we have to operate with
profitability and commerciality first
and foremost on our mind that means a
number of things we have to execute at
best-in-class levels we never let the
fact that we are a National Oil Company
get in the way of being best-in-class
and all of the key core operations of
the company whether it's our rate of
discovery of hydrocarbons how we recover
them our cost of production and if we
measure ourselves typically typically we
are the lowest cost or the highest
performance in every metric that we use
and measuring ourselves against our
peers and the competition we also have
to constantly focus on building capacity
and renewing ourselves our business is a
long-term business and being in Saudi
Arabia accessing talent is not easy so
we always have to build capacity from
within
especially training and developing our
own people and I talked about the
various people who have sent to Stanford
over the many decades and will continue
to do that so building capacity for the
company is something that we have done
and we will continue continue to do
managing execution means that we have to
work on day to day operations
extremely closely we never get away and
you have seen in the headlines what oil
companies get into if they ever miss a
step so to speak so focusing on
day-to-day operations ours is probably
by far the most risky and dangerous
business of any business out there and
we focus on safety environmental
stewardship and operational reliability
I talked earlier about the impact of
Saudi Aramco slipping on its commitments
and we never take a chance in allowing
that to happen we also have to invest
very very wisely every dollar we invest
we ensure we'll have the highest
possible rate of return the upstream is
always first but we are long on capital
so we look also at our downstream which
were those of you not familiar with the
industry that means the refining the
chemical the marketing and trading
businesses just yesterday I was in Texas
for inaugurating a ten billion dollar
refinery at Port Arthur this is an
expansion of a refinery that was built
initially in 1903 and we bought into an
a joint venture with Texaco which
ultimately became wood shell and this
ten billion dollars will take probably a
few decades for it to pay off but that's
the kind of business we're an investing
for the long term and our assets and
facilities are designed for that purpose
earlier in March I was in China and we
designed a number of agreement joint
venturing with a number of Chinese firms
to invest both in China and various
downstream facilities there as well as
cementing an agreement already in place
to build a refinery on the west coast of
Saudi Arabia so we're involved in the
Western Hemisphere as well as an
emerging markets in Asia and China is
not the only one last month
in Tokyo we had our board meeting and
one of the presentations and that board
meeting was by our upstream engineers
and scientists who were presenting our
long term production profile showing
where we would be producing literally in
the next century so we're looking a
hundred years in advance at how we will
continue to steward and produce the
resources we've already identified and
booked as well
to unlock additional resources through a
commitment to science and exploration
and investing and long-term program now
these are programs that would keep any
company extremely busy and and
[Music]
unchallenged but I already alluded to a
unique position that Saudi Aramco and
which is which is being the engine of a
whole nation of about 30 million that is
relatively early in its development
cycle so in addition to all of the
financial contributions we make the
whole nation expects Saudi Aramco to do
a lot more and leveraging our
capabilities enhancing human resource
development within the kingdom
partnering with educational institutions
today one of the colleagues I have with
me is the executive vice president of
cows which is the King Abdullah
University of Science and Technology
this is a university that we built from
scratch and we aim for it to be an
equivalent of Stanford not too long into
the future focusing on the specific
disciplines that it's focused on which
is science and technology also we are
leveraging the various downstream
investments I talked about to create
value addition and manufacturing and
attracting investment either of our own
or partners or third parties to create
value addition and jobs for a young
population which is a demographic
challenge that the kingdom and many
countries in the Middle East have a
fourth challenge that I would mention is
the fact that oil is a political
commodity it is quite intertwined with
not only economy but also environmental
issues
geopolitical issues and that complexity
creates a lot of pressure on the
industry there is a lot of debate they
say that all of the debate you hear
about energy and oil creates a lot of
heat but unfortunately not much light
and we try to do our bit to engage in
that debate so you will find oil
executives and my company and myself
engaged in discussions ranging from the
World Economic Forum to g20 discussions
to developing countries discussions like
in China when I was there in March to
try to enlighten the public opinion
about energy and the central role that
fossil fuels will continue to play for
decades to come until we're able to
transition in a more rational way to
renewables and other sources of energy
so to recap on the little deep drilling
that I was trying to do today on the
company we are the world's largest and I
would argue the most successful
unprofitable energy enterprise but we do
face tremendous challenges as an
industry and in terms of development of
our nation the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
as well as a host of other challenges we
have but I think the important thing
that we realized is we have great
opportunities ahead of us the challenges
are manageable and we are dealing with
them and what we are looking for the
opportunities we have when I took office
in 2009 and I looked at the company and
I just recited to myself some of the
things I just mentioned to you you could
make an argument that the best thing we
could do was continue to operate at
best-in-class
improve incremental e on the areas where
improvements are required
and basically protect the great company
we have however we viewed tremendous
opportunities available to Saudi Aramco
opportunities available at the
international level opportunities
available at the national level and a
huge deal of untapped potential within
the company leveraging the physical
position you we have the financial
position leveraging the talent that many
of our people want and the desire to do
more and contribute more to to the
company and to themselves and to their
nation and to the world so we launched
after much deliberation and consensus
building within the company we launched
a program that we termed the accelerated
transformation program we take this
jacket
at that time to build that consensus one
of the metaphors were used as we went
around and talked amongst ourselves as
the leadership team and then with the
rest of the company
Saudi Aramco was in an equal position to
a racing car to a Formula One vehicle
but it's a Formula One vehicle that is
being driven within the city and going
through stoplights and intersections and
therefore driving at a much slower speed
than its full potential and the only way
that Saudi Aramco would be able to
attain its full potential would be to
take it out from the inner city put it
on the superhighway rev up the engine
and get it to drive at its full
potential and basically the limitation
we figured at that time was us and we
really allowing the company to get there
or not so we launched this accelerated
transformation program and I will just
mention briefly what we ultimately came
up with which is a strategic intent of
the company and it's quite ambitious it
says in 2020 Saudi Aramco will be the
world's leading integrated energy and
chemicals company focusing on maximizing
its income facilitating the sustainable
and diversified expansion of the
kingdom's economy and enabling a
globally competitive and vibrant Saudi
energy sector so in addition to growing
the company substantially in its
portfolio we linked and to our basically
vision statement for 2020 an element of
enabling a whole national economy to
transform to diversify and to get into a
knowledge base less dependent on us as
the sole source of revenue those 39
words became basically the mandate I
give to to my management in every
interactions
with them now that's a very ambitious
program we have but translating it down
to execution was a whole different
matter so we cascaded it down into 14
different initiatives and those 14
initiatives were categorized in four
different pillars that are driving the
strategic transformation which is now
one year and the making the first pillar
is what you would call strategy 101 it's
basically reshaping the portfolio of
Saudi Aramco rebalancing the company
from being predominantly upstream oil
and gas basically producing raw
materials to one where we will have a
strong position stronger than we already
have in the downstream will be the
world's largest refiner will be one of
the largest chemical company we will
have a huge position of power generation
including you might be surprised to hear
renewables as we go forward the second
pillar was about a focused program to
leverage everything we do to help the
national economy of Saudi Arabia not
just in our immediate businesses but
extending beyond so we have partnerships
with education we have research
partnerships in the kingdom we have
manufacturing hubs that we are creating
to support us but at the same time to
create jobs these two pillars are
challenging and huge for any other
organization but in my opinion and I
think in the view of anybody who has
tried to do change within an
organization that the other two pillars
are the most difficult ones those you
can size up you can execute on you can
measure money can buy them to a large
degree the second and the third and the
fourth are the ones that require through
leadership one of them is capacity
building so reinvigorating the
leadership of the company we have a
great leadership today and we have taken
the company to where it is and there are
no regrets but for the company of the
future we need a new style of leadership
and we need new leadership capabilities
and we're working on our human resources
from the bottom up
to create the next leaders of the
company we have and four years time 40%
of the company workforce will be below
the age of 30 so dealing with the with
the wide generation so to speak is is an
opportunity as much as a challenge that
we have to seize and deliver on the
other part of capability building in
addition to leadership and human
resources is technology and building
enough research and development with the
company to keep us all myself sufficient
we have a good deal of that going on now
but we will multiply it by an order of
magnitude and the years to come the
fourth pillar is changing how we do
business I think I've described to a
large degree what we do and changing
what we do but then short change in how
we do things will be even more
challenging and that is reinventing all
of our business business procedures and
systems within the company and that is
very tough because these systems and
procedures have been good for us they
have gotten us to where we are to the
leadership position we enjoy today and
to convince people that we will go
through the change process which is not
easy and throw away the systems and
processes that have gotten us to where
we are is there is a lot of selling and
then there is a lot of pain and
execution so we've already overhauled
our planning process strategy
development as well as capital project
execution in order to get to that next
five 10% of excellence that we think we
need to get to be the world's not only
leading and largest and most profitable
but also most admired company in our
space of energy and oil and gas now
resistance to change will always be
there to any firm even firms that are in
trouble but it's particularly difficult
for a firm that is successful where the
stakeholders from the outside are
constantly praising you on being the
reliable supply of energy
all corners of the world where the
kingdom looks and your nation looks at
you as an example of success where your
neighbors are always thankful for your
attention to environment safety and
their well-being so when you come to all
of the stakeholders and say that's good
and that's good but it's not good enough
we need to go to the next level of
excellence it takes some selling but
when the opportunities are presented
that are to be attained by going through
this change I was surprised by how much
consensus we were able to build around
it and how much energy and enthusiasm
and I thought I will be pulling a lot
and now I am being pushed from the back
by the momentum that has been created
around the ATP so I think I'm taking
probably as much time as I should take
in that deep drill that I wanted to give
you on the company and our strategy and
a little bit of our history I will just
end with a metaphor if I may on how we
looked at our strategy and this metaphor
I will call on an athlete called the
great one and you'll be this is for
those of you who don't know this is
Wayne Gretzky is a hockey player and you
probably never thought that the Saudi
oil man will be will be giving you a
metaphor about a hockey player but Wayne
Gretzky is reported to have said I don't
skate to where the puck is I skate where
the puck is going to be and that's
exactly how we think at Saudi Aramco
we're not running after what we're doing
today we're running after where we want
to be in 10 20 30 or even 50 years from
now and we're trying to position the
company to go from the greatness it has
achieved over almost 80 years of history
to leading our business and sector for
80 years to come and of course I would
just caution that thinking big and
thinking's
tjak you should never lose sight of
managing execution managing day-to-day
and staying fit
I'm sure Wayne Gretzky had the smarts
and had the sixth sense of knowing where
to be but he also worked very hard of
being as fit as the other guy and
working well with the team which is
exactly what I try to do building a
strong team within my company and a
strong teaming relationship with the
partners we have around the world so
that's all I wanted to say in my opening
remarks and I look forward to the Q&A
[Applause]
thanks again for joining us Jeff review
from the top it's it's very fitting to
have you as our last speaker for this
series given the value of Saudi Aramco
he's greater than the combined value of
all of our prior 12 CEOs that we've had
you talked a lot about education and the
investment Saudi Aramco's making I had a
question from a personal side what role
has education both your time here in the
US and your graduate school played for
you as a leader and shaping your
thoughts about leadership well I for me
it works in two ways
I would say education has taken me from
my humble beginnings where quite frankly
didn't have a view of the world where I
am today and and for that I'm very
thankful but the flip side of that I
think an education is it taught me how
much I don't know there are things I
know and there are things that I
continuously learn which is something I
learned in school of course I'm sure all
of you have learned great things but
rest assured in 10 years most much of it
will be obsolete so the beauty about a
good education is it gets your curiosity
and a willingness and an ability to
constantly renew your knowledge and
learn new things but for me also
importantly is taught me how much I
don't know how much out there that could
be learned if not by me directly at
least by my colleagues by my institution
so planted in me a belief that without
pursuing the highest degree of education
as an individual as a family and my own
family as an institution and Saudi
Aramco and as a nation you are not only
stand still but you actually slip behind
because the world is constantly advanced
and we all need to keep pace and for
those of us who aspire to lead you just
need to lead through education and
that's a belief that I try to as I
mentioned planted in the family and the
company and in our interaction with the
kingdom educational institutions it's
great to hear I know you've done
tremendous things around education in
Saudi Arabia
another question that I had was around
as a leader you inevitably must face
setbacks that come across in decisions
that you made what have you done to kind
of face them and you can give us an
example of a setback and a lesson to you
Tron from there I'm not sure I should
get for example I'll talk to Natalie you
know I think in life in general whether
it's in business or in our private lives
the road forward always has zigzags so
if you believe in yourself and if you
believe in your values and if the
objectives that you're working for you
take those setbacks and stride and you
know there will be a better day and of
course one thing that I talked to my
colleagues in the company especially in
the reinvigorated Saudi Aramco over the
future that we're trying to take is we
have to take risks and risks means that
many of the decisions we make we will
try to mitigate the risks we will
calculate and we will develop what-if
scenarios and doesn't work what do we do
but once we make the decision we accept
that it may fail and we move on we learn
the lessons and move forward so that has
been a motto for me all of my life
rarely have I met all expectations that
I set for myself and series there is
always every so many steps forward there
is a step back and you just work with it
great well I'd love to open it up to
questions from the audience at this
point Authority
and thanks for coming you talked about
the importance of planning long term
including hundred years ahead given the
changes in the industry including the
fracking and shale gas extraction
discovery of oil in Utah as it was
nuclear explosion how do you see the
changes in the industry and how are you
going to respond to that change
strategically well we have been arguing
for a long time way before the
unconventional game-changing
developments here in the US became
common knowledge that the hydrocarbon
resource base on earth are huge they are
not what is booked today as conventional
oil reserves there is a lot more that
will be added to reserves as the
technology develops and the performance
of the industry improves in terms of the
rate of discovery and recovery of those
reserves improves and the last 10 to 15
years have proven us correct we have in
the u.s. now added production and and
the US has reserve has reversed its
production decline that has been taken
place for for a number of decades and
actually now the u.s. is increasing to
us that's a good thing because it proves
a point that Peak Oil as it was called a
few years ago is not accurate at least
in terms of the timing of of when the
decline will take place that we have
many many years left and the resource
endowment of there to manage the
transition of an economy and a global
society that is dependent on
hydrocarbons today to other renewable
sources and other alternatives that will
be developed more economically
in a more rational fashion if we allow
it the time to do that so we don't have
to respond our production will continue
to be there
Saudi Aramco will continue to be the
lowest cost producer for as long as
there is oil production in the world and
the last oil produced I assure you will
be produced by Saudi Aramco and the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia so we have
nothing to worry about from the
unconventionals
we welcome them and I think we also as I
mentioned earlier welcomed the role of
renewables and we will be working
ourselves with renewables to provide a
diverse energy mix to you know to a
world population that needs it
Saudi Arabia takes some criticism for
internal energy consumption levels and
do you as a leader of the domestic
producer you know think about that or
have influence on that we think about
that and we have influence about that
and we talked about that we in fact the
first alarm bells I rang them a few
years ago in a talk in Riyadh the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabians since then the
dialogue has continued and there is
increased awareness I would just caution
that some of the numbers that are
published are exaggerated and they're
all and all assuming you know the as is
conditions continuing that there will be
no introduction of efficiency measures
that the kingdom will continue to be
wasteful and energy use in the future
and that's not correct the government
has taken on a number of serious
measures including creating an agency
that is focused on bringing and
renewables and nuclear to complement oil
and gas in the energy mix there is a
center that has been set and Saudi
Aramco is participating in it to bring
an efficiency and utilization of energy
and of course we're busy exploring for
and we'll be producing unconventional
gas we hope shale gas and and in the
future that will displace some of the
oil and oil products that are being
consumed domestically so we allow
student question hello my name is fawad
Saudi from Lebanon so it's an honor to
have someone from our region
representing Saudi Aramco my question is
Saudi Arabia and a lot of other
countries in the Gulf have historically
relied on talent from outside the
borders to build a lot a lot of their
great companies and now there seems to
be a push from governments whether in
like the UAE or Saudi Arabia to push for
the local workforce to counter and take
on more of these roles like memorize
amortization understood in the UAE or
salad
and Saudi Arabia and my question is what
are your thoughts on these initiatives
how does it impact you as a business as
well well I would I would go back to the
story I mentioned about the American oil
companies you know that owned Saudi
Aramco we give them a lot of credit for
investing and in Saudi as a Shahnaz you
call it hammered and localization and
you know some of the graduates I
mentioned our chairman who graduated 50
years ago actually out of Stanford were
sent by the American company so it is in
our heritage we are not getting
directives to do it
we've always been an in terment today we
have 80 nationalities by the way in our
workforce so we're quite a diverse
company with both genders working within
Saudi Aramco and 80 nationalities
representing most countries in the world
but the fact is most of our operations
today are in Saudi Arabia and it makes
sense to hire local whether you're a
Saudi or not it's more cost-effective
more reliable less turnover and it just
makes good business sense so we've done
at all these decades on the basis of
being a good business and we are a good
citizen of course we our company is not
going to solve the employment challenge
in Saudi Arabia as the Dean mentioned
55,000 56,000 employees today and a
country that needs millions of jobs but
we try to create job opportunities in
the business sector that we deal with
our suppliers or customers our
contractors we give them training we
work with them hand in hand to create
job opportunities for the hundreds of
thousands of Saudi jobseekers that great
and I'd like to ask one last question
before we wrap up a question that all of
us here at the GSB answer in our process
to be admitted here is what matters most
to you and why people have answered from
a range of family to reading books and
would love to ask you that question how
you
answer it as a leader of such an
important company well one thing is
difficult you know obviously the
emotional side comes first and one has
to say my family is first and that's
that's the truth but taking that for
granted that all of us have their
families as their first instinctive
thing if you they care for then what is
the next thing and for me the next thing
is making an impact that that will be
remembered and will be important for all
of the stakeholders that I can impact
the employees of the company the
shareholder and the nation of Saudi
Arabia and the global community that we
serve as a company so running the
company the best way we can to meet its
objectives and expectation the
legitimate expectations of our
stakeholders to me something that I
think about constantly it is more than
having a good financial performance at
the end of the quarter or at the end of
the year it's more than finishing a set
of projects on time on budget it is more
than the short to intermediate metrics
that we all measure ourselves it's
something you know a higher purpose that
I believe Saudi Aramco and everybody
that works in our company serves not
only ourselves as employees of the
company not only our nation as the major
stakeholder in the company but an every
meaning of the world the global
community which the company serves by
providing reliable supplies of energy
and keeping the global markets stable
for as long as we can great please thank
me thank you join me in thanking mr.
Farr
[Applause]
change lives to be done July's change
organizations change organizations
change the world